hey trash bag slugs thrown in the trash
can whatever your names are
i am on the road i will be at helium in
buffalo new york
on july 30th and 31st i will be at the
tempe improv in arizona august 6 through
8. i will be at caroline's
in new york please come to that i'm so
excited to go back to
uh new york on august 12-14
and we'll do the rest of the dates next
week
but it's very exciting you can go to my
website andyletterman.com and you can
pick up my
drawing on a shirt hi slugs i'm really
excited because my clothing line
sleepover by esther has a brand new drop
finally it's the twilight zone
collection i'm wearing the pants right
now
black and white with alien green logo
and
here i'll model it oh god my midsection
blur it out
um also in october i'm coming to florida
dania beach
uh uh where am i going i don't remember
it'll be on the screen but come see me
in florida this october
[Music]
first of all i have to the elephant in
the room is my beautiful voice
i had a cold or something and so i
sound what do i do i sound you sound
like you're mocking me you sound like
you're making fun of me
to me i sound so different like you can
tell right you sound like annie
really yeah but you know what the more
you talk i think you had to kick it up a
little bit
what do you mean like you sound the more
you're getting animated and like you're
the life is coming back into you the
less you sound
oh that's good but this is a point where
it still sounds sexy
it could go spiral down into something
else craw like frog croaky is definitely
in the
in the like playlist when i first met
when i first talked to bobby on the
phone because i wanted to talk to him
before meeting up with him because
i was paranoid if he would be like a
dick i wanted to vibe him out did you
think maybe he was catfishing you
um no no not that i was afraid i wanted
to know if i
even wanted to meet him at all and see
how he was on the phone like what's he
like
but i had lost my voice completely and
just little
sprits of sound would come out oh listen
like this that was so bad
that's like so scary so he thought i was
catfishing him
like he was like i think this is a man
trying to sound like
and you have those shoulders i had a
shoulder holders the stomach shoulders
never help
well esther like what i would do in your
scenario which you would never do this
is the obvious
opposite thing you would do in the world
i would take the moment of your voice
being deep
i would buy like a carton of newports
right i would just do it i would yell
into the
ethers and then when it was as deep as
it could be i would leave my voicemail
message
oh my god i'd be like hey esther
but it is weird like why is your voice
like the way that it is and like what is
that
i think i i think since the moment i
could talk you were smoking never
stopped smoking yes
wait have you always had a raspy voice
even when you were yeah i always had a
yeah
but i am is there like a scientific like
are your vocal cords i was diagnosed
with newports in middle school middle
school
no they i went to you actually really
like this i went to
my commercial agent's uh place in new
york years ago
and there was like the head guy was in
this like big room and i still like to
go in and like be like oh my god i
tried to be scared of him i was like oh
my god it's like the big head honcho
and um i would like pop in and one day
he goes you know i'm just like
dying for his approval and wanting him
to say something against me he goes
he goes oh my god your voice he um
he goes it's so and i i said unique and
he was like damaged what
happened to you it was so funny but you
know when i went to spain
all of the women there sound raspy and
sexy and i don't know it's because if
like spanish people have to roll their
r's a lot or they just have a very like
heart on the consonants type of but i've
never met a spanish woman that didn't
have a sexy sultry voice
what you know what you know what it is
it's the spice and the spunk
you know in the go-go they're swallowing
that and it's it's terrifying i've tried
that
my whole life and it has not worked yeah
it's weird i don't know like it's
i'm just curious is there something like
if i if we look at
your vocal chords and your vocal cords
are yours like
polyp probably i mean there's probably
herpes all over them or something our
ears like help us
she won't stop but there is i did do i
did an episode of the show
years ago with joel mchale it was this
like spin-off show of the soup called
the soup investigates
and the episode that i did we were it
was when vocal fry had first come out
it was like the kardashians were getting
big and i didn't even associate
that joke big butts don't say your jokes
bad
they didn't know we'll clip it we're
clipping out one and she said it was bad
but um we'll put it at the end of my one
of my jokes like esther's being mean
um but so the i went and talked to this
like speech expert
and she said that they think it started
in
when women were going into the workplace
to like have a deeper voice to sound
more
vocal creative yeah that it was like
they were like trying to match men's
voices
but then i'm like vocal fries sounds
kind of but there's
there's a there's an inflection in vocal
fry that makes it vocal fry so there's
like a pause right
do it so like like there's like a long
like a
and that's what i don't like about it
it's like is that it
honey did you try it do it everyone do
it you go first danny
that was natural that was an impression
of me now you're here
no it wasn't a queef after you go
she i don't know i need you now's your
moment okay i'll do it like
like oh my god really
yeah it's like a long drawn out like ah
uh-huh
that's actually pretty good well i did
the show i learned i learned from this
woman
tell me what to say um say i like go go
on my
no no nose i
really like go go
oh my god you did it what this hair
changed dude
wait why are you okay
okay you hang on the y long so then it
fries out
you're welcome boners no this is like a
podcast nightmare i feel like
all people hate on podcasts is when
someone has vocal fry
and now we're just giving it to them
straight up serving it fresh
but they never they people go through
trends of what they hate
yeah it's it's a new thing each time you
know
there was the worst thing ever changes
yes it does it's it's it's like in the
zeitgeist of what
like podcast listeners are going to hate
for a while it was like
people have kind of dropped yeah i like
because at this point
i i i blame my so-called life the show
for why i say like so much
i was so obsessed with that [ __ ] did you
watch that show um i've heard of it that
was my sister's big show
like always on and she's obsessed it's
good i so i like hate it because to me
it just reminds me of like the time
where i wasn't allowed to watch cartoons
you weren't allowed to watch the
twilight zone you freak you weird
oh my god i really actually am getting
attracted to you why i mean first the
hair
looks like you're just becoming nice
you're slowly becoming me
your sweatpants are higher than usual
wait she has an extra pair of hoops
annie throw me
no no no no if you well these are the
ones that went through the nipple
no and also those look so heavy like how
do you wear them they're nice
they're not heavy they're so long
oh my god they're so light esther put
these through your nipples right now
these ones put these through your
nipples right now that's crazy
you guys if esther doesn't get her
nipples pierced i'm quitting the shower
i do think a small
barbell in a nipple are you honestly
something happened when they dyed your
hair i've always thought that
the girl the girl there were cool girls
in high school got it without me i told
you
do you have a twin sister you didn't
tell us about who's traded places with
you like in
in big brother when they do that there's
just like one they trade out
you guys watch big brother yes of course
i watched that season you didn't you
stopped watching i did stop but that
season i did esther connie can find you
about something you're a stupid [ __ ]
because you used to watch like live
feeds with me and [ __ ] yeah yeah
the live feeds of big brother was that
was like i wasn't like leaving my house
because i didn't want to what are you
leaving your house to work you can't
leave your house if you
hate to bring him up again but i think
eric griffin was on board with you when
like big brother
uh mania really yeah i think he's super
obsessed with it too
hate to bring him up again hate to bring
hate to bring him up
we just don't want to bring up the fact
that he told us we that we had to wear
lingerie
i love you eric he's engaged he's in
case that's amazing congrats eric
holy [ __ ] eric you got engaged before
kalei
gilbert got engaged before me he did
yeah guilty guy i thought you're gonna
say gilbert got engaged before he got
circumcised can you believe it
also a fact oh my god
oh my god what if he put the ring in his
his like pee skin
his pee pee skin yeah and then when she
folded it back the ring fell into her
hand oh that's romantic
it's just a white little cheeky you hide
it in the turtleneck and then you pull
back the turtleneck and then there is
the ring
that is so surprising and romantic it's
not
it is romantic by the way yesterday um
sir what yesterday we were shooting
dollface and kat
dennings was like oh my god like
everything's so different now like
shay and brenda have babies i'm engaged
she's like esther you're engaged i was
like i've been engaged since before the
first season
like esther got you gotta do the same
car but a newer one
esther so i hear there there's been
backlash about your corolla
dude the people are like coming from
either like you
are wrong why would you get a corolla
you should have gotten a tesla
it's people are mad at me about the
corolla and i have i have
what can you pull up with the amount i
bet you this is is this one or two
comments
no no no it was like it wasn't that much
but it was
it definitely has like stuck with me and
i just want to say
that i come i came to my conclusion
because i you know i'm like did i make a
mistake like should i have gotten the
tesla
and now i've decided that a tesla has
[ __ ] i made it energy and i'm not ready
to have [ __ ] i made it energy
i'm like i'm still on my climb and i
don't want to like
roll around town being like like i
there's something about it that makes me
feel something about you saying roll
around town that does fit you
but there's no car involved push me
no esther um they have not
until you've lived a mile
sleeping in moyer's basement you will
not know what it's like to be esther
you can't your dad would disown you yeah
and also
you also have to understand that this
car is 20 years newer than the car i was
driving before
very big so i feel like i'm driving
around town in the nicest car
ever look i stand at corolla you guys
know this
i will put hands on anybody who says
that you should have gotten a tesla
because then they don't know who you are
obviously the white is the issue i have
why you are the you are the
as far as cleanness you are a lazy [ __ ]
and they get dirty so fast it's
yes i did you get it to match your
favorite liquid death
no i got it i told you guys the i heard
once that white is the safest car on the
road
because everyone can see it at night
because everyone's like oh i always
thought
everyone's like look at that card i've
never been someone to
stop and look to see if a car is dirty
at all
like i don't look at a car and be like
wow they haven't gotten a car well
obviously we've seen your
urine bodies park well that's not my
fault do you drive
i drive i drive all the time but you
have no car
no i had um you guys i'm from the hood i
used to have a
expedition i used to i used to drive a
really big accident
and annie knows the story but when i
first started dating bobby
um i parked in front of his house
because i couldn't park in like the
guest spot it was too big
my car was too big so i would park
outside and bobby drove into it like sam
tripoli
[Laughter]
but then um it was a difficult part of
my life so
um this is when i was coming out of
nursing school i was i feel like i was
spiraling
but um i racked up a lot of tickets and
it got impounded
and then i just said let go let god and
see ya
that's so hard wait can you do that her
car went to prison
yeah and then i never got bailed i never
bailed him out did you never get right
you never got another car so you never
needed to do registration because
sometimes they'll get you with that on
the next round
no i haven't had a car since i haven't
had a car in almost 10 years
i asked bobby that's the other night i
said i go who drives when you guys drive
and he said he does
he does but with your heart condition
honestly
he does for short distances and anytime
we go to palm springs or anything far
that's when he pins it on me
yeah and then what he does is really
rude because at least when he drives i'm
always like an active co-pilot
yeah like i'm active on the music i'm
active in conversation what he does
is he lays the seat flat and he knocks
out and i'm all alone in this five-hour
drive
but do you lead a normal life like what
if
did you have to be like oh bobby has the
car today so i can't like well bobby
doesn't go
anywhere either so i actually drive more
than him
i end up you know if i go to the beach i
take the car also i have the hours of 8
am
to 3 pm to do whatever i want because he
doesn't wake up right
3pm so i can live a whole life before
then i know i've told you this off of
the show before but
i used to have a boyfriend who would
wake up at like
5 p.m i would have gone to yoga jiu
jitsu
like i would have like had a whole day
gone on a lunch date
like had so much fun my whole day i come
home and be like cooking dinner or
whatever and he would like be like
i never have any space and i'm like
[ __ ] it's been i've been up for
12 hours what are you doing about you
yes that was my covid life because as
you guys know dave
slept until like four o'clock every day
so all day i was just like
lit i was alone and talking to everybody
yeah yeah you were never alone you were
on facetime with me the entire time yeah
todd just is like so used to just
he like he i'm assuming can sleep
through this or he just suffers
quietly but i will just if someone
facetimes me in the morning i will just
he's just like it's fine like i was like
is it okay and he's like and then i'll
just be facetiming while he's still
asleep
i can actually go through that too that
doesn't annoy me at all
i like when i'm asleep and the world is
fussing around me that's a good feeling
do your animals wake you up at night
because i'm going through a really
difficult phase with donut where at 4am
she does these grumbles like these like
grumbly noises and she doesn't stop
until you get up and walk her to the
water bowl like she's thirsty in the
middle of the night and it's driving me
nuts
can you move the water ball closer we do
excuse me but she wants you to like lift
her you have to like stand
you have to escort her and she really is
her mother
that is really she's just mirroring what
she sees is that crazy
is that bad dave make her popcorn in the
middle of the night
my dogs don't wake up until i wake up
she used that's how she used to be
like i don't they don't dictate my sleep
wake cycle
i dictate theirs i would never live have
it any other way you're the alpha so you
just have to alpha hurry yeah yeah
i am not that donut is the alpha in mind
no but you have to switch it
i i refuse dogs are pretentious carlos
are above me does randy ever wake you up
in the middle of the night
randy doesn't wake me up in the middle
of the night but randy gets up like an
hour
probably earlier than i would sometimes
but i've trained him now i went out
while todd did i guess i went out of
town
and tal just ignored him when he whined
so
now he just if i can i can be quiet
i can tiptoe out and i can go like
take a [ __ ] and like go get coffee
without him and then take him out
afterwards
but um if he wakes up for a second
we're going out yeah my dogs are not
like super regimented in that way
i also like i don't know if you do this
but like
i maybe you don't but i think do you
feed her the exact same time every day
no she has free range to the food like
oh yeah
but she never eats because she's scared
to eat if this is like a whole thing
randy gets at night like randy will wait
until like late night
he's just like oh i have feeding times i
have designated feeding times but then
can i say can i come over for a feeding
time that sounds really fun
will you serve me a bowl but i don't
again it's like it could be an hour off
you know an hour earlier an hour later i
don't like to
spoil them in that way yes because it's
like
well you do have to be their leader you
really do like and they will
yeah they will do what you say yeah so
they don't they don't command me to
anything
i would love to be a dog in your pack
that would like i would feel so sorry
about a hip and she'll
bring right over oh yeah just get down
cut an arm off
we should probably talk about this since
this could potentially happen to you
so there's this girl who had tonsillitis
and she went to the hospital and she got
her tonsils removed and the next day
when she woke up she had a full-blown
irish accent
what that's so funny i swear to god
george pull it up
and so i want to know she's trying if
you were to wake up with any accident
after they take your tonsils out
what would it be british right like i
feel like you have to say british
it's like the commonly like if i had an
asian accent
how do you not say british what what are
your guys's answers you don't know any
other accent that's so funny
what else is there i want like a thick
baltimore accent
what is it baltimore it's the same it's
exactly the same as philly it's like so
trash it's like
it's just the same like it like well for
philly it's like over easy eggs over
there like you guys like
oh my god like town mayor of east town
yes
i used to be in the i don't even want to
do those anymore i really am
working on not having any darkness
around me
is pretty dark
do you ever feel like something is just
preventing you from achieving your goals
what isn't preventing me i am a child of
trauma
or something is maybe interfering with
your happiness yes
well you should check out betterhelp.com
trash
tuesday because i know i have anxiety
and
i really need more than just the normal
life i need help that's why i use better
help
and better help will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
yeah when i um realized i'm in fight or
fight
i you know you got to talk to someone
you got to talk it out you need someone
that's a trained professional
that you can connect with in a safe and
private online environment which is so
convenient and you can start
communicating with someone in under 48
hours from right now
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional
counseling done securely online and my
favorite part about it is the journal
feature so you can send a message to
your counselor
anytime and you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule a weekly video or phone session
we want you to start living a happier
life today and as a listener you'll get
10 percent off your first month by
visiting our sponsor at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over one million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health again that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-dot-com trash
tuesday you guys lucy nicotine is a
company founded by caltech scientists
and former smokers looking for a better
and cleaner nicotine alternative finally
tobacco alternatives that don't
suck yeah and it is like when i say this
when i'm going to like go smoke a
cigarette or do something it's like
there's a thing i want to do
so lucy gives you that thing it's not
all the gunk of cigarettes like this is
when bobby has to travel
on long plane rides this comes in really
handy and it's researched and developed
for three years so you made four people
not
patients and lucius created a nicotine
gum with four milligrams of nicotine
that comes in three flavors
wintergreen cinnamon and pomegranate and
lucy also has a lozenge with four
milligrams of nicotine that comes in
three other flavors cherry ice citrus
and mint and these
lozenges and gums are fsa and hsa of
eligible
so you can use your fsa cards to
purchase lucy now
and it's convenient discreet products
can be enjoyed anywhere on flights like
kalila said
at work on the go even in the gym i
don't know why they still have all the
cigarette holders in the
bathrooms in the airport by the way that
is weird they should have lucy holders
they should have lucy holders
it's 20 21 get rid of your cigarettes
unplug your vape throw out your dip and
get some lucy nicotine gum or lozenges
this is the real deal a subscription to
lucy comes directly to your door each
month and it's so simple you don't
ever have to leave your house because
lucy has delivery down
lucy lozenges and gums are also fsa and
hsa
eligible so you can spend pre-tax
dollars on them trash tuesday listeners
can go to lucy.co
and use promo code tuesday to get 20 off
all products on your first order
including the gum or lozenges
that's lucy.co and use promo code
tuesday
at checkout lucy.com be sure to use that
promo code
tuesday also i have to give this
disclaimer warning
this product contains nicotine derived
from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical
let's see her accent george lenny this
video is for you
i woke up this morning i didn't do
anything different
i had breakfast i didn't really talk to
my housemates because
lexi had gone to work already and sasha
i don't think she was up before i left
i took a shower and i i usually sing
when i'm
it really is showering listening to
songs and all of a sudden
i was talking in an irish accent oh my
god and i thought initially that that
was just something
i was just hearing that this can't be
real and
now i can't shake it oh my god
what did she have before what was her
action before i think she was just an
american accent
um it's totally not normal and i'm on my
way to the hospital steward is coming
soon
um and i'll keep you posted shut up but
it is like
it sounds like conor mcgregor i do like
an
australian accent that's like kind of
sexy i have a little bit of
australian ptsd because less boyfriend
type stuff but
um yeah i love new zealand new zealand's
my favorite
i don't remember what a new zealand
accent is it sounds
like oh good so good it's the best
i i can't do it oh i'm kind of hearing
it it's so good it's the best
can you do it i can't do it i don't know
what esther heard i heard you kind of
doing something you just are attracted
to her no
i know you're trying to put a thing on
her to like take away that it's not just
hurry attracted to you
annie so baltimore for you esther
australian
i'm going to say british i feel like you
can't go wrong yes but
england
are you from essex are you like i think
no no i think i think
i'm like hello i do would you like to
you're a posh
one yeah
could i get you some more refill would
you like fries with that
no i'm irish um yeah i think british
right
i don't know i'm gonna start i'm gonna
start doing a hypnosis where i try to
teach myself
to let loose with accents because i do
have like when you do accidents do you
get like a
fear of being doing a bad job uh no
i'm a mimic so for me i just have to
listen
if i hear it like when we went to when
me and dave went to australia
we like i could nail it but it has to be
fresh
and i mimic it and then i'm like fine
but it is a listening skill
yeah that's all it is but i get really i
was um
my ex boyfriend or this guy that i was
dating before
he asked me to do a trump impersonation
once and i what
yeah he just was like he was just like
try because i was like i want to see if
i can do like impersonations but i
didn't mean like right then
and he was like alright to trump and i
just like i don't i went like oh you
know like i don't know what i please
do it no but i really i couldn't even
tell you i just did like nothing i was
like um
the country or whatever and he was like
he started laughing at me and i had a
visceral
like breakdown you got like panic fight
or flight
like red like red like it was like the
most
i don't know why that was well it's you
know that's saying in therapy if it's
if it's hysterical it's historical so
there might be something like
that someone made me say do trump boys
before yeah no but it was you know when
you were
down yeah i was like yeah maybe
i do remember wait that did give me a
flashback and you know
it was that part of your brain where the
memories it was in that part of where my
clipping is you can feel it
my track oh my track my track's bringing
me back
um no i okay so i love attention there's
no
i will never hide that uh my whole
family has attention however
when i was like eight or nine or ten
somewhere that age group my
we went to the phillies game for me my
twin brother's birthday
and i said to my mom do not i go mom
you're not getting the philly fanatic to
come do because they would get like the
philly fanatic as the
mascot and they would come like poor you
know confetti on you and they put you on
the jumbotron and i was like
you're not doing that my mom's like no
and i was like okay good because i
really don't want that
and she's like okay so we get there and
that [ __ ] philly fanatic comes and my
swim coach was there was like so
embarrassed
and um my swim coach was oh my god baris
i almost i'm turning into sebastian
that's my my tonsil accent embarrassed
but so then so then um and i remember
feeling so humiliated and betrayed by it
my mom was like what was i gonna do i'd
already gotten it i was like well you
kind of warned me
oh no but i was like so but but isn't
that weird that i love
i mean i couldn't want attention more
but that's like being caught off guard
though
that's what i wanted to ask you esther
like i know you hate surprises right
but how are you with surprise parties
like if someone threw you a surprise
party
you know i so for my 30th birthday my
best my childhood best friend
surprised me by being at my house and i
was it was amazing right like it was so
wonderful but then
i had this whole night this party plan
and i was like
well my best friend is here i just want
to hang out with her so like i was like
i would have done this differently
so i still stand by that i don't think
surprises are good because there's you
can
plan better but i do like surprising
people but
i do want to say i have oh she likes to
surprise but doesn't like to be
surprised well like in a safe
like for my mom's 60th i surprised her
and that was like amazing like we pulled
it off
can you tell the story well it was just
my dad and i for like
for some reason like for six months we
talked every day about like coordinating
the surprise of just like me hiding it
well i know why you had to talk about it
so much is because your mom's usually
the one that does all the work so you're
like
we're gonna have to figure out how to do
this stuff without her is she a hard
person to surprise
well it's hard because like we all have
each other's locations so i had
so i had to like power i had to power
down my main phone because i have a
second phone
so like you have a bad phone
so like it was just there's all these
like little like spy techniques we had
to use like my dad oh my dad had to
leave his phone at the airport when he
came and picked me up
so my dad and i had to like plan our
meeting space at the airport
there was just these little things but
it you know it ended up being great
and my mom was so shocked and it was
really funny but i didn't do a reboot of
harry at the spy but it's you
i know you're a kid but yourself i want
to be a spy so bad that was like my past
time in high school was me and my best
friend would spy on her brother and his
friends
what would they be doing playing video
games touching penis tips
we i want to say though your story about
like that scary story at the game
when i was little i was at a birthday
party where there was a magician
and the magician came up to me and was
like have you cleaned your ears lately
and i was like i don't know
and he pulled something like you know
like a ribbon or whatever out of my ear
and i just started crying it was like i
have to go home now
it was like the same thing is that why
you've never cleaned your ears again
well you're not first of all you're not
supposed to clean your ears you're not
supposed to put anything in your ears
you've told me about this about vaginas
you tell me about this about a lot of
things esther
pretty soon every inch of her body will
be just like mine
but it is like scary to be put on the
spot like that i don't know
it's like embarrassing it was
embarrassing it felt like halloween when
i was in fourth grade
i we were doing this like all the kids
were painting each other's faces chasing
chasing each other around and i had a
crush
all colors okay the rainbow just making
sure i don't know about what your people
are up to
i but um we couldn't blackface blackface
annie
we're black people of asia no but um so
all the kids were painting each other's
faces and i saw my crush
and he was having a good old time he let
all the girls paint on his face we were
just doing this and doing that so i was
like this is my moment
so i got a big wad of paint and i was
like hey
paul john his name is paul paul john let
me paint your face
he turns around he's like [ __ ] off in
front of everybody
and i ran crying to this day
to this day i am not over it
i am not over it that was one of the
most humiliating things
why did he do that i don't know let's
find him george
pull him up paul we got him on dot com
paul john
paul johnsmom.com
i have i was gonna say i have a boy
story that i'll never forget from when i
was in kindergarten
but it's kind of the opposite
were you the mean girl to him no no a
little boy in kindergarten
like he liked me and he gave me a ring
and i was so i know i've talked about
this before
i was so like grossed out and like
scared and like hated it like you know
when you just
you know when you're that you know you
know what you're that age like where
boys are just awful like it's gross
yeah i went home and i buried it in my
backyard i was like
i don't want this to exist i don't know
how to do it and then the version of him
grew into a tree
like ugh every day this is not what i
wanted
but it was like it just did you do you
have any memories of being younger when
the opposite sex was so icky to you it's
scary
i remember being so boy crazy and having
a situation
like at my summer camp there was this
counselor named brady who i was like
i mean i we had a quiet time that was
like
you failed it no well i think i had to
be quiet
this might be my only this might have
room they implemented it for you well
think about this i also was like a
quaker we had like
science meeting for worship is silence
they've been trying to
the universe has been trying to silence
me for quite a while and i won't be
taking that
it won't be happening but so um so
during quiet time you're supposed to be
like writing your parents or taking a
nap
i would like white knuckle and be like
creating so hot like i just like
like hugging a pillow like i just like
couldn't like deal with how hot he was
and so then after quiet time the bell
would ring and they would have like free
time
and you could go they would have for
snacks you could go get fruit they would
have a bowl of fruit
so i go to get the fruit i'm probably
like 11 or 12.
full hansen like looking like such a boy
like you can't look more like a boy
do you have the voice uh i don't know
i'm sure i probably did have the voice
i mean not the singing voice but
obviously the husk
and i there's one orange left and brady
also comes at the same time right
to get the orange but i already have it
and i go ha ha
i got it and i throw it at him but i
nail him in the nards
i get him in the balls and he like and
he like topples over and then i'm like
what do i do
like i don't know how to save this so
then i was like i gotta double down so
then i took the
thing and i squeezed it on him and he
was like what the [ __ ] and i was like
so you don't want to go to the dance
with me on the lights yeah it was really
that is a good move to double down
though just because it's like i take the
control back so now i'm like
now he doesn't like me but it's like
because i well now you're just because
now you're just a bully i couldn't even
say that was that the moment
like that changed you forever were you
like a nice girl until that moment
you were just a little girl who liked
brady
no one really called me a little girl at
that time i was on this
um facebook live audio thing with
christina p
and um katie morton who's a therapist
and one of the questions um
group therapy or like it was this
facebook live
it's therapy but you get paid but um she
asked us she's like what would you tell
like your 14 year old self like what
would you say
and oh my god i never really thought
about it because i think about what i
would say to like
a young young me like eight years old
but not like a teenage
me i got choked up was it because you
were
gagging on dr [ __ ]
what did you say i remember now but it
was something a little remember
it was not like today it was short-term
memory oh my goodness no i said
something along the lines of like you
know just like
hold out like life does get sweeter or
like i know you hate your mom now
but she's a really good guy yeah she
cleans well
yeah he's gonna drive you to palm
springs one day and let me tell you
that's really gonna feel like i drove
no one no one drives me on these long
long distance road trips i have to drive
those
one time my ex-boyfriend i went on a
road trip he by the way cheated on me
the entire time it was so weird i'm like
we were just going on a tour of him to
like bang anyway
just one girl but he cheated on you
while you were here okay we were
friends with them we're cool so we had
been friends
in college and i had had i always had
was like the person that would have the
prospective students stay with me
so like people that wanted to go to my
college would stay in my dorm and i
would like on recruit trips
yeah and i would like we would just give
them
my friend my boyfriend and i would just
like give them like the best
time they could like yeah we're like
what do you want coke yeah we're going
to get you a chicken
trips are hardcore i came back we're
gonna have them do we tell them to cut
out all the stuff dude it's true
i went to on a recruit trip to ohio
state and i came back with double
pneumonia and was hospitalized for two
weeks
yes that's how it should be because it's
that's on recruit trips you just get so
[ __ ] up yeah you're showing them like
it's the school is cool yeah
so i had two i had two prospective
students and
the one girl was like kind of like the
sweet one and she lived in napa valley
so we were in santa fe
so we were like why don't we go after
like it was like a month after spring
break so we're like
why don't we just go in spring break to
go see this girl
in napa valley so we go on this road
trip and i didn't really like want to be
girlfriends with my friend but he was
like
he pulled the move where he was like
you're either my girlfriend or we're not
friends and i was like having so much
fun with him because he's
yeah his personality disorder was really
fun sometimes and then not fun other
times and really fun sometimes than not
but i don't want to out him but um so
then
but he was a kanye of sort of he was a
yeah he was kanye ask except less of the
yeezy part
wait how is he kanye bipolar yeah it's
okay
but so we so we go on this road trip and
we took
my parents car i had my mom's credit
card he ran out of money like
immediately so then i was and he was
like a rich kid but he just like
lied and said you didn't have money like
for this trip so then i was like
[ __ ] so i had to charge the credit card
so we were in the middle of this but i
was still gonna have to pay the credit
card off
so then i end up like being 1800 we
drive to napa
he starts banging this girl i'm like i
didn't even want to be your girlfriend i
would like go take a shower and they
would hook up
and then um when we drove back he slept
and i listened to angela's ashes oh my
favorite book
oh my god but frank mccourt of course
that's your favorite book
and tis tis is after what is that about
uh
well let's just take the part ashes
what is it it's dark it is about a
family in ireland
yeah um but it's back during the time
when the consumption
tuberculosis they lived in like poverty
it's just this story of this
sort of is a rags to riches because he
does end up in in um
um in college and i remember liking this
book a lot because
angela's children died it was sad it was
really out of
dying like a consumption children it was
very very what i loved about it is the
way he wrote there was almost
no um periods or commas or pop proper
punctuation
do you think i've ever read a book and
haven't had these [ __ ] read it
to me in my ears you're crazy oh my god
it's a memoir
it is because and it's also like a
stream of he writes more like a stream
of consciousness it's so casual the way
he writes that it's so transfixing i
swear to god estrogen
is so sad but so i'm listening to this
it's raining he says he's cheated on me
i'm like is this like
are my tears or the raindrops i don't
know it was like so sad i was so
depressed but
we got over it he paid me back years
later years later he
uh bought me a bunch of stuff like that
nice like really nice sunglasses
actually i think he stole me expensive
sunglasses but he bought me a lot of
dinners and like took me shopping and
stuff
yeah i like school really my my one of
my best friends married his brother
so we're all cool i don't this is okay
i don't know if taking me up to a meal
is a good way to ping someone back
because then i'm like
well we have to i have to hang out with
you to get the food
well it was fun to see him he's okay
bipolar so he's very very very
very very very when he's on he's on and
when he's off
scary um no he was not violent
you guys let's talk about upstart okay
if you're carrying a credit card balance
month after month it can feel like
you're in a never ending cycle of debt
but upstart can help you make that final
payment so you can get ahead
if you're like me and you dread looking
at your credit card statements
you're not alone that can feel crippling
but upstart can help you on your path to
financial freedom
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment and upstart
knows that you're more
than just your credit score and it's
expanding access to affordable credit
unlike other lenders upstart considers
your income and current employment to
find you a smarter
rate for your loan i'm more than 69 is
that what you're saying
upstart believes in me with a
five-minute online rate check you can
see your rate up front for loans between
one thousand to fifty thousand dollars
and you can receive funds
at as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
tuesday that's upstart.com tuesday
don't forget to use our url and let them
know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application
go to upstart.com tuesday
you guys real talk shopping for new
clothes can be so
stressful so why not let stitch fix make
it easy by doing the work for you so you
can spend time doing the things you love
instead
maybe you've gotten used to the work
from home routine but has your wardrobe
adjusted esther
oh my god i now i have to actually like
be out in the world wearing cute i want
to have cute
looks you know stitch fix offers
clothing hand selected by expert stylist
for you
for your unique size style and budget
it's a completely different and fun way
to find clothes that you will love to
wear every piece is chosen
for your fit and your life and it's the
easy solution to finding what makes you
look and feel your best you can try the
pieces on at home before you buy
you keep what you love and you return
what you don't stitch fix has free
shipping easy returns and exchanges
and a prepaid return envelope is
included it's so
it's genuinely so easy the only way
you're returning stuff is if you're
getting it from
yeah stitch box in there my favorite
part is that there's no subscription
required okay so you can try stitch fix
once or you set up automatic deliveries
if you want to
you'll pay just a 20 styling fee for
each box which gets
credited towards the pieces that you
keep and there's no hidden fees ever
get started today at stitchfix.com
tuesday and you'll get 25 off when you
keep everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com tuesday for
25 off when you keep everything in your
fix
stitchfix.com tuesday
it was really like it was so fun to see
him because the way i saw him i was this
was five years later he had moved out of
santa fe
and i had harbored like a lot of anger
towards him like my mom had come for
some reason was just visiting me
and he was out the window and my mom
like went down to go like get the money
back and he like drove off like
he had been avoiding this money which
was so funny because he couldn't they're
from like greenwich connecticut
yeah he could have just spent the money
but for some reason he just like didn't
want to give it to me
which is a good lesson because if you do
end up like footing a bill for someone
or lending someone money or whatever
happens like
you are giving money away because you
just have no control over whether
someone's gonna
you know it was just really so i'm
working at this restaurant the cowgirl
and he just
walks out of the bathroom i haven't seen
in five years and i my instinct was just
like pure joy like i was just so happy
to see him
there was no anger and he's like i'm
sorry about the money he's like let's go
shopping like it was oh that's nice he's
just so
like it was really fun we had a great
time and uh
yeah we've i mean i've had like tons of
good times with him since like and i'm
you know
it's all good but you're right it's not
like the real thing but
how would you like a lot and that's
where i think you should stay you should
really get the
because that's the only way you can
really take him to people's court you
know how would you like
um to be compensated esther well i think
that this is because there was an
incident in my family
where my extended family like not my
immediate family but
my grandpa lent someone in our family
money
and instead of paying him back they
bought a new camry no
they this person paid him back with
vitamins
oh did it extend his life no okay
because she had like a vitamin company
okay and like was it a real vitamin
company or was she like doing new like
was it like herbalife
it wasn't quite like herbalife but it
was just this running joke
in my immediate family of like you can't
[ __ ] pay someone back with vitamins
bro
like but how did your grandfather feel
was he pissed probably yeah
like when his own children didn't pay
him back he was
he was mad like that was he he was very
like you know
he was took that seriously that's that's
the reason for a lot of resentment in my
family like in the philippines
especially
because at first it's like oh i'm a
little bit more
um in a position of of like financial
stability compared to them right yeah
so i obviously like i i put several of
the girls through school or the kids
through school
but then it turns actually mostly the
girls
um but it turns into this it turns into
then they ask for something else and
then when you say no
they forget that they're you're putting
their children through school they're
just
remembering that now they're going like
you're the bank so now they're like but
you already gave it to me so give me
more
yeah and then they're angry when you
can't give them more than what you're
already giving them
and and but they that gets thrown in my
face a lot well you know we're not as
lucky as you or we're not this
is like the guilt trips it's like this
really sick sick sick cycle to a point
now where i'm like
all my money is taken care of by my mom
and i'm like
at your discretion because i don't want
to ruin my relationships with these
people
everyone knows to go to my mom now not
to me i should do that i should give my
dad all my money but then
las vegas would have a really good
weekend but he still wouldn't have
hearing aids
well you could do this esther is like i
give a set amount now like every year
and i hand it to my mom and i'm like
this is at your description i don't care
who you give it to because my mom is
yeah she's the business
manager right but it's not more than
what i
would be uncomfortable yeah it's more
not more than i would be comfortable
with so yeah i'm like in a similar
position as you like
my immediate family like knows that like
i'm the one
like if there's an issue come to me for
money but i'm also not like
i don't know it's it's definitely a
complicated situation but i'm i'm like
i'm
you're not rich but they know that you
you're the most you're the closest
i'm like just let me know what you need
like let's talk it
like you know i'm trying to like empower
my parents to make their own money like
where it's like my mom because my mom is
she was like
yeah she's like you're just so young you
have so much like opportunities i'm like
mom you're [ __ ] writing a book why
are you right
like she my mom's like doing all this
research
and she's writing this book about a mill
girl back in the day and she's like
doing this like
children's book and everything and my
mom had when i was growing up she wrote
this is so gagable
she wrote romance novels like oh that is
and they never got published
which means they're just like [ __ ]
journals but she can self-publish now
no but here's the thing she did end up
self-publishing a book but that was
about me and we don't talk about that
because it's from the dark wait
what i know this is exciting it's too
upsetting okay i can't be triggered
i can't believe we love mama i do love
my mommy i love my mommy is the best
mommy mommy mommy mommy i'm like do you
like that book [ __ ]
mommy mommy do i know about this i'm
just forgetting i
yeah i'm sure i've screamed it towards
annie
look at me your mom and you holding
hands in the rain i know i love her
you love her very much i love that
[ __ ] [ __ ] she wrote that book no
she wrote a book about raising troubled
teenagers loosely based on me and the
board is so dark and so mean to me and
so nice to my brothers
so bad too like you gotta understand my
brother he would like
my mama take the car after my brother
would have it she would press the break
and like
empty 40 bottles would work i'm like
he's drinking and driving in high school
i'm the bad guy because my friends get
on to prison excuse me
this is a comment that's a common thing
of like mom
favoring the sons like i feel like
everyone i know who is a girl with
brothers
this is or they expect it from the boy
or something and the girl's supposed to
be like
the girl has higher standards but also
she was a good girl and so she's seeing
herself
you know whenever there's like a [ __ ]
me too thing that comes out and all the
guys are always like
but i mean what if he's being and we're
like we were raped
do you know what i mean whereas like
everyone you kind of like see yourself
in like whatever
gender you are in that remember your
joke there was the funny will you please
say it
about like when me too started happening
you're like guys are
i'll say it guys are all scared that
they're gonna be accused of rape
like don't you think we're scared of
being raped like isn't that worse
i remember getting in a fight with one
of these comics i'm friends with because
he was like my biggest fear is being
used of rape and i'm like you're
like you're like i could think of
something worse for me
that's bigger i'm like so it all leads
to you
eventually getting butt raped but like
we're just raped very
like on the first level we're raped but
um
but also i've been thinking about how i
love men recently so
i've been thinking about i don't want to
be a man hater anymore i would i want to
like release that sort of energy
and i just surround myself with like the
goodies but that was a dark time in
comedy oh my god
right when everyone was like i'm like
just like it was just like trigger
trigger trigger trigger and i also
understand like
that that's a real thing too but i would
have to have this conversation with guys
where i'm like
oh i don't know what to say i know
that's a fear but
mine happens more often and more holes
i i learned a lot about i i i'm not a
man hater at all i have a lot of like
wonderful men in my life
why did you say to the man yeah but
he did my face man voice hater when it
comes to that topic
like i've been able to recognize what
deserves my voice and what deserves my
silence
and and it's one of those things like
annie says where it can it can really
spiral you especially if you've been
assaulted especially if you
you almost have to like protect your
piece first so you can't get into these
like
it's just not my pro like honestly it's
like i sat in court i'm good
you know what i mean you had your day in
court i did my time i just don't want to
be on jury duty anymore
but i do i do notice that it's like the
guys just because it's like it's human
nature the guys are gonna go like
oh my god my worst fear would be that
part and then ours is like oh my god our
worst fear is this part but it does all
end up in some sort of
vaginal or anal raping if you think
about it if you really break it down
you know you really gave that story a
beautiful ending yes you know i just
wanted to give it a delicate sort of
like brown
flower at the end what's your guys's
experience with jury duty i'm so glad
you didn't say rape
oh boy i'm like i'm so disappointed
give me a second chance but and that but
the reason i was saying this because i
think my mom was thinking like
well i was a good girl so she should be
okay yeah and like boys are boys
but anyway i forgive her but she did
write this romance up this is what i
want to say and we'll get back to jury
duty
my mom wrote this wrong the most
exciting topic in the world i know you
must get one
from the woman whose favorite book is
angela's ashes it's not my favorite it's
just
top 10. she's going to be like i love
jury duty
actually jury duty can be exciting but
sorry okay why would you like taking her
it's like if it's a murder it could be
fun yeah no but like but then you see
real pictures though
i don't know where i'm trying to go with
this go back to yourself okay you'll
this will bring this to you so my mother
wrote a romance novel and she was a part
of this thing called romance writers of
america
and she wrote a book and it was called
selena's revenge it was like a
an action romance and there may have
been time travel i can't really remember
but um i you know i can't read um
so she so that was just like a thing
that happened when i was
you know in middle school or high school
then
i go to like some meeting at comedy
central or someplace and one of the
one of the receptionist is there and
she's reading a book and i go oh what
are you reading she goes oh nothing and
i go why are you embarrassed what are
you reading and she's like
it's just a book about writing romance
novels she's like i write romance novels
and i go oh my mom
uh used to write romance novels and she
wrote a roman song and she went to
romance
writers of america she goes oh i'm a
part of that and i go yeah she won
best like uh best book or something
best new book she'd like won this award
and the googleberry
something but she go the girl goes she
goes that's such a big deal
she's like that's such a huge deal she's
like when did it get published and i go
oh
i don't know and then i talked about him
she never followed up she won and could
have had like
a hit book but she just like was i guess
got like in
ahead of like in her own way and never
followed up
so then when i'm talking to my mom now
and she's like you have all this earning
but i'm like
[ __ ] you're writing a book like why
don't you just like
make it a money maker just make money
esther you um i talked to you last week
and you
asked me if you what i thought about you
how you would fare in nursing school or
as a nurse okay
oh my gosh i was thinking about this
because my uncle's girlfriend or i guess
beyonce
she had just um passed her test and
like everyone in my family was so happy
for her and i was sitting there secretly
i was like
you guys think you're happy for her you
don't know how happy i am like another
nurse in the family
like this is so huge i was so happy and
then i started thinking like
because she was talking about how hard
she'd been studying and how nervous she
was to pass this test
test and it got me thinking like
should i like become a nurse like i love
nurses so much
how big of a deal how hard
give me the real like i have a theme for
the next episode george
sexy a work attire okay sexy nurse
you'll be something funny i'll be
something sexy construction worker
i don't know why but klyla like
how delusional am i like how just tell
me what you think can i tell you
okay i think annie i'm so sorry when i
said i'm gonna bring randy's balls what
was your reaction
okay well that is what's kalila's
reaction
i think you're uh you get queasy very
quickly especially if it's not your own
fluids you're dealing with yeah nipples
are involved with nursing school you
know something
it seems as though you're okay with your
own fluids and maybe
someone close to you but if it's a
stranger
like it's a very thankless job
oftentimes wow
um and on top of that um
i i do think you're a loving person i
just i can't view you in like a
caretaker rule
she's lying look at her i just said
i do think you really i care taking is
even me i can't do it there's a reason
why oh my god you're such a caretaker
what about if i just went to the school
part
but then like i just like used that
knowledge like in real life
like i said i wanted to take math
classes you're like you're a [ __ ]
idiot
so i'm gonna say to you you're a [ __ ]
remember that faster you will get
through
the the actual like um the the test
and the books and all of that stuff but
you do have to do clinical rotations
that's right you have to be
in the hospital are you interested in
being able to like diagnose yourself
more
no i just feel like being a nurse is
such a [ __ ] like life skill
like just knowing kalila i feel like has
elevated
my world and i'm like oh what if i could
be that for like oh my god
i'm just thinking of all the
misinformation that's going from kalila
to you out to the world
it's like a game of telephone and also i
i never finished college so i feel like
i have this
this bug in me of like wanting to like
here's what i'll say finish something
out see something through learn
something
here's where i have a little bit of beef
with
nursing schools in general and how they
can be so far up their own asses
i went to cal state long beach and it's
one of the top nursing schools in the
country
surfing schools too and surfing schools
good volleyball team
wow um but they basically tell you this
when you get accepted into nursing
school
say goodbye to your friends your family
your social life your travel plans
and they paint this picture like it's
some sort of like the hardest thing
you'll ever do in your life
and it just simply isn't true i think
anyone can do it
i think that if you while nursing is a
really hard profession
it's just school if you and i know you
do school well
so if you just commit to it like i don't
like how they discourage
a lot of people from doing nursing
school because they say you won't have a
life
i [ __ ] i've never traveled so much
when but dude
when you're a nurse it's going to be
hard to have a life no because you work
three usually it's three on three off
right when you're finally in three days
yeah three days on three days off
well how long does nursing school take
um
for me it was uh the stupidest idea i've
ever had
i support it but typically it's two
years two years okay
yeah and i i do think you'll get through
do they do they let you
out in time for your comedy show at
night when did you become canadian did
you get your tonsils out
wait i have a question how far did you
get into college
i got halfway through my junior year and
then
but your classes have since expired so
you have to take all your prereqs all
over again
really yeah i think so what was your
major
modeling i you know what i love is that
i think you really believe that
i started as a dance major and then i
switched to acting and then you thinking
those are different from hand modeling
is crazy
and then i landed on journalism and then
um yeah
oh my god did you learn anything in
journalism i wanted to do it i took well
nothing i don't
nothing comes to mind but i took um
an investigative journalism class and
that was so much fun like
just learning about like a deep dive
into like how journalists what they do
is i was like oh this is cool they like
really go digging
i always what what why are you just
looking at the trackers on the phone
it's all i'm thinking of you sure now
actually digging
you would be a great creative agent
thank you i don't think you'd be a great
mortician
that's so cute i know cia agent is like
my dreams
i think oh wait i thought you said cia
you said caa
you actually honestly might be a good
caa agent
no i don't want that no you are good at
gathering intel
there are some times where i've talked
to for five hours and i realized
literally
you've only asked me questions i'm a
questioner how good are
how good are you at keeping secrets very
good oh my god
look at her she's dating a man
she's engaged she's really taking this
one far no like
i'm i'm yeah i can definitely do that
because i yeah foot fetish men are going
to go wild if they can what because i'm
itching like they're just red
little you see how you make their
penises look so big
that is a i think that is a plus with
you esther i think you'd make any penis
look annoying thank you so much for that
amazing compliment such as they look
small on your teeth you're giant oh yeah
they look so small with your tits
my arms are not even that big i'm just
short so they look big on me
your tits on me would still look giant
on mine as well
what if ours are the same size no carly
and i carly aquilo and i have
twin tits you guys are when we've we've
been topless together it's like oh my
god
that's the same boob oh you were topless
together tell us more well then what
happened okay engaged to a man
i've been topless with we saw it i saw
jenna the other day
yeah and i was like oh i've seen your
vagina and boobs
on jenna wait i saw her it was like the
third time i'd mentioned the comedy
story
the main room show had ended already or
there wasn't one that night so it's like
pitch black in there and we just had
enough light to like kind of go in and
hang out
we were sitting on the stage we were
sitting on the stage like this empty
like little semi-circle and we were
talking about
vaginas or tits or something female body
parts
and we're like for some reason like like
you know how jenna
jenna's a friend of the show jenna is
short for genital um
you know she's always whipping that puss
out jenna is
so jen for people who don't know jenna
is my friend from college but
she's very close with you and bobby and
when i met jen in college it was jenna
was like a star
to me like i just remember seeing her on
the campus and being like
i'm going to see her vagina that girl
this girl is so cool
anyways see her and i'm i don't really
know jenna but
unless you think seeing someone's full
vagina is knowing i can only see full
vaginas
it was probably full of vaginas yeah it
was like i mean i didn't see that where
it ended in the back but
i didn't see it if i know jenna at all
you've seen
her actual cervix that's because
but she was saying that i think you had
just been waxing her vagina
had did you ever wax her vagina for her
i've done other things to her
nah not waxing what other things well no
like
sometimes we're gonna taste it sometimes
like when i first met her
you know it was just a whole lot of like
what is your vagina what does mine look
like let's look in the mirror together
also disgusting is this an ingrown or is
this herpes
yeah i don't like that kind medical news
medical news
did you pop ingrown hair for her oh my
god no just this one hamstring hair that
she had that was like coiled in there
for years
oh years yeah i call dibs on certain
ingrowns on people if i see them
like do not touch that i'm coming back
tomorrow with my gear
and i have my little lancet it's a whole
thing here i just picture you suiting up
i do i wake up extra early go for a jog
like that's my day i want to know what
kind of helmet goes like this
i was like she's such a theater major
she can't help herself you go for a jog
like
that's so clarice darling of you like i
just picture
but is it you're going through a jog
because you you've you've grabbed the
end of the hair and you have to run
around to pull the whole thing out no
this is just
all prep for what is gonna happen which
is i'm gonna pull out this
40 foot long ingrown and it's going to
blow my dude
and give me some popper yeah i've been
following dr pimple popper i was
probably her second follower
like i've i've been on her she's never
responded to me ever one time
i tweeted
i made bobby tweet her one time a
picture of my friends
what we think was like a pile of cyst
on twitter i was this is when bobby and
i were first dating i was like well
like my friend just doesn't have
insurance she can't see a dermatologist
this thing has been there forever we
need your celebrity
yeah i was like i need you to do me a
favor guys she's not a gold digger she's
a pimple digger do you understand
do you get what we're talking about here
see and so i was like
please tweet this i was like he has a
check mark a blue check mark
i was like he's gonna get i was like
jessica hang tight we're gonna get this
this taken care of
and she never wrote back so that was a
big business has
grown and grown and grown while we're
talking about these other
like second career possibilities me as a
nurse or cia agent
is there a possibility for you to have
like a a
pimple-popping clinic or something
pimple popping clinic
and we'll do the dance and the
merchandise um
that would here's what it is i don't
want to be a fake
pimple popper i only want to do honestly
i want to be a blackhead queen
i just want to do straight blackheads or
um depows
dilated poro whiner what is that what's
that it's just it's basically like a
giant blackhead
oh i've seen them yeah so you'd be like
an extractor i just want to be an
extractor but only for obvious ones that
are
that that i because if i don't get a
thrill it's not worth my time
like some of them you can we're not
enough for the money i'm not in it for
the money i'm in it for
intrinsic reward she's not in it for the
[ __ ] she's in it for the bus
wait annie what would your second career
be oh
what would you be if you weren't work at
the zoo because i got so much
[ __ ] uh what practice with you guys
uh no uh what would i be i don't know
special ed teacher
wait weren't you supposed to be a dog
trainer oh
i really was supposed to be what we
should call rex because this does sound
like a lie
i met this man i was drunk day drinking
literally weeks before i quit drinking
and um i was wasted smoking a cigarette
outside a bar
this ripped like bodybuilder guy walks
by with two
corsos like these giant [ __ ] guard
dogs
and they walk by he walks by and then he
like snaps they sit they lay down they
do like it's just so impressive and i
went
i went oh my god what are you this is my
exact words i'm wasting like
what are you like are you selling an
energy drink i want to buy it are you
giving a seminar i want to take it
and he's like i'm a dog trainer and i
was like i want to be a dog trainer i
need a job and he was like okay
and then i like met up with him again
and he was like all right before you
start training the dogs
because his job was to train guard or uh
fight dogs
they would they would rescue fight dogs
and then they would train them to be
guard dogs
so this wasn't just like training
[ __ ] donut and randy right
even though it's probably way harder
even though no one has mastered that
so i like before i could work with the
dogs he's like you have to
um work on your leash work so he gave me
a leash
and i would have to work on the um
[Music]
on fences i would have to click to a
fence outside and i would have to
like train an invisible dog so i'm in my
peak alcoholism i'm just wasted on the
streets
jacket zipped open it's snowing i
probably have my tits out
i'm just like pulling a a leash and
going like
no sit good boy and like petting an
imaginary dog
and honestly they always have you over
accentuate the good the goo
dog i'm putting this dog that doesn't
exist and so i did that for a while and
then he
sent me to the they had a farm with this
guy roland that he worked with
and so i went to the farm i remember
calling my dad ahead of time like hey
i'm going to this farm i know i have not
met these people
it's in upstate new york i don't quite
know where the place is called skinner
road and he's like skinner road he's
like this is a snuff phil manny
or something this is a snap film but so
i went and
they had like the kennels and stuff and
they had an area where you would put on
a bite suit i did not get in the bite
suit yet that was going to be the next
hang
but you're getting a bite suit and you
have to train them to bite to train them
not to bite
so um i just helped like clean up their
[ __ ] and like learned about
different training techniques and stuff
and then
i went back to new york and they were
like all right let's talk about money
and i go okay cool and they're like all
right we're gonna need you to be on call
and i think it was like ten dollars an
hour and i was like oh no i'm a comedian
i can't do that
i was like i do open mics and then so i
just stayed friends with rex and never
did
but that's what happened well that's a
dream that must be a common thing for
comedians because
when i trained to work at uh the hard
rock cafe in hollywood
i literally went through like three
weeks of training
and then at the last minute i was like
oh i have a show and they were like oh
it's over now yeah it really oh [ __ ]
yeah why did i just train for this job i
can't do let me see if rex
picks up here let's do a banana break
while we wait for this oh yeah
[Music]
who is this this is alba facilities
alba facilities well watch our podcast
as trash tuesdays thank you so much
it's on youtube you'll love you really
will like it trash tuesdays it used to
be called bloodbath but it's a long
story but you should watch it it's on
youtube you will like it
oh thank you will you comment if you do
really watch it
okay thank you you're gonna like it all
right okay bye
what if that's how we got all our
listeners we just called random numbers
i'll take a banana today
that felt validating that other people
had called it's available
something's happening to you it's the
bleached hair no you know what it is
it's
there's less stress about eating the
banana because it's it's in its package
so my parents uh really got like shamed
me for not eating bananas when i was
home
they're just like you should eat bananas
i don't know all those [ __ ] collisions
something that they have didn't
discipline you in so many ways and
that's the way
they just like whip you with the did
they beat you with the
just no that's what her mom did yeah
oh yeah remember the picture yeah oh my
god
um did you guys hear about that man who
got swallowed by the humpback whale
is that moby dick why did he bring up
books you know i don't read
he was like a fisherman and i think he
was this is the plot
i know he okay three weeks ago okay is
he okay yeah he's alive to tell the
talent
michael packard was lobster diving in
cape cod on friday when he says the
humpback whale sucked him right into his
mouth
before spitting him out after 30 seconds
he was just going along
and i just happened to be in the wrong
place at the wrong time
whale of a tail sounds fishy goes this
headline you would expect more serious
injuries one cape cod doctor was quoted
as saying
he had no soft tissue damage and no
broken bones
but this 54 year old scuba diver says he
totally believes the story
i believe it fully it is possible why
because reiner schimpf had an almost
identical experience back two years ago
and has the photos
that's his body sticking out of the
mouth of a whale who'd swallowed him off
the coast of south africa
he was filming footage of the sardine
runs
this would really piss me off imagine
being actually swallowed by a humpback
whale surviving it
and then inside edition being like well
this is fishy here's the thing they
always though
it was fishy i was with a thousand fish
in there gonna go
with the pun yeah they're gonna go with
the pun as someone that makes
tries to make click bait himself but um
are you a him are you referring to
yourself i was pointing at
george young ginger so let's go with
succeeds
well the last one wedding was it could
have been
esther's the come queen i think we might
have gotten a little bit oh my gosh
um how are you feeling about um
being crowned the queen oh my god we
really have to revisit this it's the
funniest thing that's ever happened
in life this is the highlight of our
entire bucket list
still george george is still you know
it is what it is she came down with a
cold soon after
yeah so back to my humpback whale esther
do we think that this is real that it
did happen and this man did
yeah right like would he you really
think he could get this far with that
lie
like how what's he trying to ink like a
deal with
about his story with the story's already
been done right so here's like what is
he
what is there to gain from saying that
you got swallowed by a whale
you know i wouldn't have thought that it
could be a lie but then again there are
those people out there that like will
make up those crazy things
just you know you said wouldn't wouldn't
yeah it was cute
wouldn't oh maybe i'm british now like i
said no i always notice when she says
cute things
wouldn't i gotta even it out what
wouldn't um i don't know annie what do
you think do you think it's real
you know what i actually don't care
here's how i feel about it here's how i
feel about it
if this man wants to go go to the
trouble
go go if he wants to go into the side
no i just think honestly it's like if he
wants to
make up this tall tale i'm proud of you
you're creative do your thing
if you did get swallowed by a whale and
people are coming alive i hope he
has the strength inside him to not give
a [ __ ] and obviously he knows whether
it's true or not but
you're always going to get caught a liar
i've got a liar a million times it's
like
i don't lie i know i'm not lying but it
sounds also though like he didn't really
get swallowed it sounds like it took it
in their mouth and then they spit them
out
oh that's going to be memed oh my god
[ __ ] and go go queen
i damn it no but i but
i mean it's a cool story i don't it's a
cool story bro whole story bro
chill [ __ ] gets wild by something
another thing
annie's only interested in the lobster
that she saw now i am thinking lobster
i'm thinking lobster i actually
i i saw the clip of esther um talking
about how disgusting crab legs are from
two episodes ago and i i i'm upset
they're
they're not my uh not my taste not my
preference
that's what i've learned to say when you
don't not to like yuck someone's yum
it's not my preference yuck someone's
young again that's a memer
oh i'm sorry that's gum someone's dick
that's what know i'm so sorry my god
i am going to be such a good [ __ ]
giver in my 80s that's all i can say
well i guess this has been another
another ridiculous week
where the come queen was referenced for
no reason out of nowhere
well sometimes [ __ ] comes out of nowhere
you know it's just
right in the face i don't know if i
agree
i don't want to bring up that i've been
molested but
oh gosh oh boy you know what i want to
do next week
this is what i'll tease i want to talk
about the sun the sun block
the sunscreen poem from baslerman
i think we should write a new one i
think we should write a new one
i made you and dave listen to it or did
they bring it up to you or something
there's something you talk yeah where he
says wear sunscreen yeah
i think that's what it's called but
there's like a whole it's like really
great advice it's really beautiful
advice but i think we could rewrite it
in our own words
we should do because the basilar men we
should designate
um stan line by line to each other and
then we'll
we'll read it out loud okay put it
together and then we'll read out a new
version without looking at each other's
first
okay do you know what i mean yeah you'll
explain it to me better later and then
i'll know well we'll write you the
instructions but also the
like you just write each other's part
and then the other person has to read it
okay right is that you mean like what
happened yeah
i explained it poorly but i'll do a
better job later that's a good example
like
you think you understood and i know i
didn't like that's how bad we both have
our own way
but then i'm really codependent so i
could have easier
yeah at the same time yeah well thank
you for joining us
for another episode of trash tuesday
we'll see you next week
one day we'll have a better name one day
we promise you that
we do promise you we promise that trash
tuesday is very temporary
we'll figure that out soon yeah thanks
everyone and next week i won't be this
sexy husky boy scroll so enjoy it while
you got it and i will still be this
but you'll still have annie you'll still
have me
you